[Musica]
io oggi ho un compito molto ingrato però
quello che il Manzoni diceva non va mai
fatto Manzoni parlando del Don Ferrante
dice È incredibile l'autorità di undotto
nel dimostrare nel convincere gli altri
di ciò di cui sono già persuasi io oggi
farò proprio il contrario cioè cercherò
di convincervi del contrario di quello
in cui Voi credete molto probabilmente e
anzi nel tema del nel titolo che noi
abbiamo posto impossibile e oggi farò
una cosa ancora più aggrovigliata cioè
cercherò di convincervi che la cosa che
voi pensate è probabilmente la verità
più ovvia più di buon senso quindi la
cosa più possibile è invece
completamente impossibile e viceversa
cercherò di convincerli non ci riuscirò
sicuramente che un'alternativa che
sembra a prima vista completamente
impossibile in realtà tutto sommato è
l'alternativa più plausibile di tutte
il problema di cui voglio parlare è
sostanzialmente Che cos'è la nostra
coscienza coscienza che cosa siamo noi
che cosa siamo nel mondo fisico e perché
dico nel mondo fisico dicono il mondo
fisico perché la scienza e io pur
essendo un filosofo
aveva iniziato la mia carriera come
ingegnere e però come diceva De
Crescenzo adesso sto un po' meglio
come filosofo sono in realtà un filosofo
naturalista come Galileo anche Galileo
quando è andato qui in Toscana forse
assumere da Cosimo secondo de' medici ha
detto vengo però mi assumete come
filosofo naturale e che cos'è un
filosofo naturale una persona che pensa
che la natura contenga in sé la propria
spiegazione e che quindi noi dobbiamo
essere in grado di trovare nel dominio
delle cose la cosa che noi siamo quindi
la domanda della coscienza che oggi di
attualità perché l'intelligenza
artificiale si comincia a chiedersi se
acquisteranno anche la coscienza e la
domanda senza tante complicazioni sul
che cosa siamo e già una domanda diversa
dal chi siamo perché già se noi
chiediamo chi invece che cosa stiamo
introducendo un doppio livello nella
realtà
E da questo punto di vista I filosofi a
volte chiedono chi e a volte chiedono
cosa noi qua cercheremo di trovare una
risposta all'interno del mondo fisico e
per questo che un tavolino pieno di
oggetti
perché gli oggetti sono la cosa di cui è
fatta la realtà gli oggetti e le cose
che fanno tra di loro secondo la natura
la natura è fatta di cose e noi dobbiamo
trovare la cosa che siamo allora
nel 1623 Galileo e circa 100 anni prima
vesaglio quando Enrico II di Francia
cade da cavallo cominciano a porsi
questa domanda e cominciano a cercare la
cosa che noi siamo dentro gli oggetti
e dove In quale oggetto cominciano a
cercare la nostra esistenza si guarda
intorno l'anima la mettono da parte
perché l'anime fuori dal mondo dobbiamo
trovarla dentro il mondo
e la prima cosa che viene in mente è il
corpo
il corpo e ovviamente il cervello
e comincia a cercare comincia il metodo
scientifico con questa ricerca della
cosa che noi siamo dentro il cervello
cercano dentro il cervello per esempio
quando questo qui che lo chiamiamo per
adesso lo chiameremo Non lo so
chiamiamolo Giovanni guarda una mela e
loro cercano dentro il cervello se c'è
qualcosa che è l'esperienza della mela
Hanno cominciato il tempo di vesaglio
sono andato avanti al tempo di Galileo e
continuano lo vedete qua alle mie spalle
a cercare ogni tipo di
candidato fisico all'interno del
cervello finora hanno trovato qualche
cosa no
posso avere la slide Grazie mille
Ecco solo una citazione da National
Science 2022
7rs of conscious solo una frase per
capire a che punto siamo dopo anni anni
di ricerca sulla coscienza Tuttavia nel
caso della coscienza non è chiaro come
le attuali teorie se ne in relazione
l'una con l'altra o si possono essere
persino distinte empiricamente
Cioè sostanzialmente finora le
neuroscienze non hanno trovato niente
come la coscienza all'interno di questo
oggetto che è un oggetto e perché Perché
dentro il cervello sostanzialmente c'è
Che cosa c'è dentro il cervello c'è
altro cervello ci sono neuroni
neurotrasmettitori accetilcolina
glia
mielina ogni sorta di cose ma c'è
sostanzialmente non c'è spazio per altro
se non l'attività cerebrale
Allora il problema qual è il problema è
che il problema della coscienza a tutte
le caratteristiche che in passato hanno
avuto gli pseudo problemi
Che cosa sono gli pseudo problemi nella
scienza sono quei problemi che non
derivano da un mistero nella natura Ma
derivano da una errata da un errato
pregiudizio sono quei problemi che
derivano dal fatto di chiedersi se dal
fatto di partire da un assunto sbagliato
vi faccio un esempio di pseudo problema
per tantissimo tempo la gente che aveva
capito che la Terra era rotonda anche
nel Medioevo avevano ben chiaro questo
fatto però Si chiedevano come mai non
cade E allora chi ha proposto Atlante
Chi ha proposto Gli elefanti che ha
proposto la tartaruga
qualcosa che impedisse alla terra di
cadere il buon senso dice tutto accade
cadrà anche la terra in realtà poi si è
capito che non si è trovato che cosa
tiene sulla terra
si è semplicemente capito che era uno
pseudo problema altri esempi di pseudo
problemi perché sostanzialmente non c'è
una direzione assoluta verso la quale
gli oggetti debbano cadere altri esempi
di pseudo problemi i picicli e flogisto
calorico lettere ogni tanto nella
scienza ci si incaglia su uno pseudo
problema
allora E se anche la coscienza fosse uno
pseudo problema e se noi non riuscissimo
a trovarla qui dentro semplicemente
perché non è mai stata qui dentro
semplicemente perché noi la stiamo
cercando dentro l'oggetto sbagliato e
perché la cerchiamo dentro l'oggetto
sbagliato perché partiamo da un
presupposto sbagliato
questo presupposto è l'idea che noi
siamo qui e il mondo è là e perché il
mondo possa presentarsi a noi che siamo
qui che Voi capite una cosa assurda non
è soltanto una cosa empiricamente
difficile È una cosa assurda noi credia
chiediamo un oggetto di far suo un altro
oggetto questa cosa qui nel mondo fisico
è impossibile perché è impossibile
perché nel mondo fisico tutto è
semplicemente la cosa che è un'arancia e
un'arancia una mela e una mela una
banana e una banana e un cervello un
cervello e un cervello
quello che chiediamo al cervello di fare
cioè presentare il mondo senza essere il
mondo non è difficile è impossibile È
assurdo quello che la filosofia ha
chiesto alle neuroscienze è qualcosa di
completamente impossibile che a me fa
venire in mente l'ippogrifo perché
l'ippogrifo Perché l'ippogrifo è stato
inventato dall'ariosto come qualcosa che
fosse impossibile anche nel mondo
mitologico Infatti a un certo punto
Virgilio molti anni prima disse Grifoni
e cavalli nemmeno nel mondo dei miti si
accoppieranno mai E allora ecco che
L'Ariosto si inventa l'ippogrifo Ecco la
coscienza questa cosa qua noi chiediamo
a un oggetto di essere un altro oggetto
e questa cosa assurda che è inspiegabile
noi per spiegarla abbiamo fatto come la
Virtus dormitiva di Molière le abbiamo
dato un nome esperienza cosciente
Allora qui dietro tre non mi tutelari
Sherlock Holmes che in realtà è un aliex
di Aristotele perché conosce il
comandoil Einstein e Galileo e tutte e
tre ci danno una chiave per risolvere
per risolvere uno pseudo problema
cosa ci dicono o si dice non bisogna
avere paura di quello che si trova una
volta eliminato tutto l'impossibile
quello che resta anche se sembra
stravagante deve essere la verità
Einstein ci dice sostanzialmente bisogna
fare un passo indietro e Galileo ci dice
che a volte bisogna fare violenza al
nostro buon senso quindi accettare che
qualcosa che pensavamo che fosse
impossibile in realtà sia possibile
allora
in questi tre minuti che ci restano noi
abbiamo il nostro Giovanni che sta
guardando
degli oggetti in questo caso la mela
L'arancia e la banana
sta guardando questi oggetti che cosa
c'è nella sua esperienza Che cosa c'è
nella sua esistenza in questo momento
qualcosa con le caratteristiche della
mela e della banana e dell'arancia
nel suo cervello noi troviamo niente che
abbia queste caratteristiche No abbiamo
detto che le neuroscienze finora non
sono state non hanno avuto successo
qui fisicamente c'è qualche cosa che
guardandolo bene Ha proprio le
caratteristiche di ciò che è in questo
momento
nella esperienza di Giovanni
il cervello Non sembra somigliare
affatto a ciò che Giovanni trova nella
sua esperienza
se noi guardiamo senza nessun diciamo
così buias cognitivo questa scena noi
troviamo che qua Fisicamente ci sono
delle oggetti fisici che hanno
esattamente le caratteristiche
dell'esperienza di Giovanni e sono gli
oggetti stessi
cioè noi abbiamo sempre creato un
fantasma che doveva duplicare il mondo
all'interno del cervello semplicemente
perché siamo partiti dall'assunto
metafisico di considerarsi separati dal
mondo che troviamo nella nostra
esperienza
e questo è strano perché nelle
neuroscienze noi non diciamo di non
essere un oggetto noi diciamo siamo un
oggetto soltanto che l'oggetto che siamo
secondo questo assunto metafisico non ha
nessuna delle proprietà di ciò che noi
troviamo nella nostra vita Mentre c'è un
oggetto che ha esattamente le
caratteristiche della nostra esperienza
e lo troviamo e che cos'è questo oggetto
è l'insieme di oggetti che in ogni
momento ci circondano e che grazie al
nostro corpo sono in grado di interagire
tra di loro
queste ipotesi che all'inizio può
sembrare molto
stravagante in realtà è coerente con
l'approccio delle Scienze Naturali
l'approccio delle Scienze Naturali ci
dice Tu sei un oggetto è questa la
chiave del fisicasmo ma non ci dice per
forza che noi siamo un particolare
oggetto noi dobbiamo trovare
quell'oggetto che abbia proprio le
proprietà della nostra esperienza
cosciente in ogni momento e l'ipotesi
che qua io faccio Quindi è che l'oggetto
che tutt'uno con noi sia l'oggetto
esterno e questo risolverebbe in maniera
Canonica in maniera classica il problema
della coscienza come uno pseudo problema
così come si cercava la direzione
lungo la quale la terra sarebbe dovuta
accadere e non si trovava così oggi noi
abbiamo un'altra direzione metaforica
l'interiorità ma Esattamente in che
direzione punta l'interiorità se voi vi
guardate dentro uscite subito fuori non
c'è un posto dove fermarvi non c'è
capite se il microscopio il telescopio
non c'è l'introspezione che la stessa
radice non c'è un modo per guardarsi
dentro quando voi vi guardate dentro in
realtà vi guardate fuori qual è il ruolo
del cervello Come ruolo della radio
rende possibile la manifestazione di un
mondo che non è qui
il cervello in ogni momento fa parlare
un mondo di oggetti che non è dentro il
mio corpo ma che attraverso il mio corpo
parla ma non uno spirito bensì un mondo
concreto fatto di oggetti
da questo punto di vista Il cervello è
più simile a una radio e la coscienza è
ciò che parla attraverso questa radio è
il mondo che trova nel nostro corpo un
cancello per potersi manifestare Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]